Welcome to another Zoom call.
We have a number of questions that got sent in.
Just another friendly reminder to everybody.
Look at the announcements on the homepage of your member site.
And please still getting people emailing questions.
Feel free to email it in labs.
Any tests you've had done.
Any new information like that that may be just a statement to
put in your file or in your notes.
But questions need to be asked on the member site.
Well, possible.
We cannot be emailing the answers back.
For legal reasons.
And then remember you have access to all the Zoom all our courses.
First question that came in is,
Bethlehem Blue, a good thing to take.
I take six drops under my tongue and then put it on Sarah Lumen,
which is like an infrared watch.
I don't know how to recall is really big of Bethlehem Blue.
It can have some benefits against parasites.
You can have some benefits against viruses.
We don't carry it and I typically don't recommend it.
Um, no, you know, there's more or more functional medicine doctors
that are using it.
I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it.
It's not something I use.
So I can't tell that too much on that.
I read that fasty naturally increases HGH,
which is human growth hormone in this article,
written by a functional medicine doctor.
So in your blog, it says not to take human growth hormone
because it causes cancer to grow in alert ears with avatosis.
How is it that HCG, HGH,
generated by fasty does good for cancer?
Does fasty also increase IGF1?
Just curious as to the difference.
So yes, fasting can increase all sorts of different growth factors.
It does increase IGF1 production too,
but typically only after you fast it.
At least the studies that I've written this after you do a 24 hour fast.
So anything fasting less than 24 hours.
Typically,
we tell people is perfectly fine for cancer patients.
If you're fasting more than 24 hours,
you do risk raising your IGF1 levels and other growth hormones as well.
That's part of the benefit of fasting if you don't have cancer.
So if you don't have cancer,
and you're going out of,
and you've done some fasting,
you never say to go out of 3 day faster,
7 day faster, 10 day faster,
longer than that,
if you've never fasted at all,
fasting is something you need to work into.
But we have had cancer patients that have done a,
a higher to starting with us,
or even after starting with us,
and they seem to do real well.
So there's the card evidence that's out there is that after 24 hours of fasting,
you do raise your growth hormone levels and IGF1 levels.
Therefore, we tend to tell people that you should limit your fast to less than 24 hours.
That's typically in our base of fasting.
When we were talking, when we were talking to the nurse at the oncologist office,
we asked about cancer feeding off of sugar.
She said she thought that was a myth because they've had out of control diabetics survive cancer.
She said that if it were true that cancer feeds on sugar,
all diabetics would have cancer,
and no more diabetics would ever survive it.
I know there's a flaw with this reason,
but don't know what it is.
I was curious to know how to respond to that.
Well, first of all,
I would not take a dogmatic position that all cancer feeds off of sugar directly.
But to say that cancer doesn't feed off of sugar,
is literally to say that you don't understand basic human physiology.
That you learned, maybe you forgot,
that you learned this in seventh grade biology.
So you learned glycolysis in seventh grade biology.
And glycolysis takes place in all cells.
And this is how you make energy, ever ATP.
So glycolysis takes a glucose molecule,
breaks it down,
and ultimately in acetylcoins,
it's a way that goes into the crem cycle.
Remember those terms from seventh grade biology?
Every cell makes energy that way.
Sodium, cancer cells.
Cancer cells actually can feed off of what's called an anaerobic cycle.
So ultimately glucose goes through glycolysis.
It makes lactic acid at the end.
Well, actually it converts to lactic acid.
And cancer cells in an anaerobic environment can feed off of lactic acid.
It's really an inefficient way to make energy,
because you make a lot more energy when it converts to acetylcoins.
I mean, it goes into the crem cycle,
and you really kick out the ATP.
But cancer cells can be damaged, especially if they have HIV,
and defects in their genes that are converting the end late glycolysis into acetylcoins,
I may not think it's too technical.
But to say that cancer doesn't feed off of sugar is really say that you don't understand basic physiology.
Every cell will feed off of sugar.
But if you want to get even more technical,
cancer can, cancer cells can feed off of other things as well.
They can feed off of proteins, typically amino acids,
but iodine, glutamine, lysine even,
cancer can be gobbling up,
iron as a fuel source.
So cancer is trying to make energy in order to continue its replication.
But cancer cells are damaged.
So does everybody that has cancer have to go on a ketodetic diet?
No, because not all cancers are feeding mainly directly off of glucose,
but all cells you do use glucose for a female.
So cancer cells certainly use glucose as a fuel too.
To say that out of control diabetics would survive cancer,
this also tells you that this nurse is not understanding what diabetes is.
So diabetes isn't that you have access glucose in the bloodstream
because just because you eat way too much glucose,
diabetes is that you have access glucose in the bloodstream because it can't get into the cells.
So the disease of diabetes in,
let's say in adult onset type two diabetes,
is that cancer, the glucose can't get in the cell
because the receptors on the outside of the cell membrane are damaged.
And all your cells are reproducing damaged receptors on the outside of cell membrane
so the glucose can't get inside the cell.
Therefore, there's excess glucose circulating in the bloodstream.
That's what diabetes is.
It can begin because a person had a poor diet and ate way too much sugar.
But a person could actually have a good diet, not eat very much sugar at all,
but with a type two diabetes and excess blood sugar.
Type one diabetes has to do with an insulin deficiency
because of an autoimmune disease in the pancreas,
what's damaging the production of insulin,
therefore they can't get the glucose inside the cell.
So in order for glucose to get inside the cell,
you need insulin made by the pancreas
and you need healthy cell receptors or glucose.
Whenever you have an issue with one of those,
you could end up with excess blood glucose.
So to say that out of control diabetics would never survive cancer
because cancer is fed off of glucose,
you're not understanding either your both not understanding physiology
and you're not understanding what diabetes is.
Diabetes is that the glucose can't get inside the cells.
So it really shows, I don't want to be mean,
but it really shows this person's complete ignorance.
Can you explain why tumoxid fit is bad?
So tumoxid fit is in a robotase inhibitor.
It is a very effective robotase inhibitor.
It works really, really good.
So I wouldn't say tumoxid fit is bad.
It is, it does its job quite well and getting rid of all estrogens in your body.
So it's the only thing that would be quote unquote bad about it
is that it doesn't job quite well and get rid of all the estrogens in your body.
So you're getting rid of, you know, your good estrogens,
not just your bad estrogens,
and you could get a lot of symptoms because of that.
Because more bones are in your body for a reason.
And remember, it's really the forehead or oxy esteroids that are really
attaching to the estrogen beta receptors on the cancer cells
and discouraging a contiosis.
It's not the esteroids or the other,
all your other estrogen metabolites or your progesterone metabolites
that are causing issues with the estrogen beta receptor.
So tumoxid fit isn't specific to only the forehead or oxy esteroids.
It's taking away all your estrogens and doing so.
It could give you a lot of symptoms.
Can you explain why mammograms are bad?
Well, well, in my opinion, mammograms, you know,
are a lot of radiation for the information that you received.
So if I was a woman and I wanted to examine where my,
if I had breast cancer, I would certainly do,
if I didn't know that cancer, I would certainly do a thermography
to do subscreening.
So using mammograms with the radiation that you're exposed to,
it is screening to, I think, is not,
well, why is you practicing medicine?
Using mammograms after you already know you have cancer
increases your risk for a number of things because your breast is squeezed
between those two plates.
You could damage, you could actually, you know,
damage a encapsulated tumor and cause it to spread.
You're also radiating that for no reason.
It's not a treatment level of radiation or damaging cells.
Increased number of mammograms via,
or a screening tool can increase a person's risk of cancer
just due to the rad exposure of radiation.
So you've got to look at any test to go,
what's the value in this test?
What's the information that's gained from this test?
And then do I have to balance that value of that test to the risk of that test?
Just like, you know, people will ask,
well, I don't want to do a CT scan because it has radiation.
Well, I get that, but there,
there can be your,
the value of the information that you'll gain from that can outweigh the risk.
So there's times to do a CT scan.
I don't want to do it in my eye because of the gadolinium.
And I don't want that to die.
And that's all good for me.
I get that, but then you got a way out is the value of the information
that you're going to gain from that test,
worth the risk of the radiation or on the gadolinium.
And you got to weigh that out and deal with that.
That's why I always said,
if you're going to do a test that is more invasive
as side effects that come with it,
then you have to ask yourself some questions.
Well, is the information that I gained from this test,
going to change the way I'm going to treat my body?
Is it going to change the way I'm going to,
the course that I'm going to treat to,
maybe I'm going to,
if this was the information that came back positive,
I may do a course of radiation or chemotherapy.
If the answer is yes, I might do that.
Well, then the information always,
the negativity, then go ahead and do the test.
So those are the things you have to weigh out and do in any test.
Is the ketogenic diet critical for bladder cancer?
Typically, no.
I don't go, the person asked this question,
I don't know what we tested you on,
is the cause or the dietary driver of your cancer.
But certainly even if you've been following that well
and your cancer is growing,
there's certainly nothing wrong with trying a different diet
and going on ketogenic is,
I wouldn't say it's necessarily a radical diet,
but it's a much more difficult diet to follow.
But it's certainly nothing wrong with going on,
nobody's going to be injured by going on a ketogenic diet.
The only thing that I would say is if we found that your cancer
is driven by proteins,
typically a ketogenic diet is going to be high in proteins.
So you do our risking that.
But again, if your cancer is growing
and you want to make some changes,
cancer can morph and change.
And sometimes it's good to try a different diet like that
and give it a try for a month and see if there's any shrinkage
of the cancer because cancer is constantly trying to morph
and change its fuel source.
So I don't think there's anything wrong with trying
to ketogenic diet if your cancer is going the wrong way.
Is it necessary to do anything else other than the homeopathic
you recommend to mitigate the effects of CT PET scans?
Does the right cavity help pull things to do?
And if so, how often do you do this?
And do you do at pre-imposed scans?
So the homeopaths, you can start taking it pre-
before you scan.
You can start taking it any time.
So if you don't have, you know,
everybody's got radiation and they're not even getting home.
So I'll help your body pull that out.
But again, it's a homeopath.
It doesn't work quickly.
There's nothing else you can really do to keylate that out.
If you're using a die,
that you can use some other keylators,
like different binders,
like the clear binder,
or Pectisol C can be helpful.
That can be beneficial.
Anything with the right, I'd say,
that I had pro wave,
that's what bad.
Doing the clearline detox would be helpful.
But you don't start that down afterwards.
Probably been doing some of those already,
but doing the clearline detox,
once a day can be helpful for me.
Oh, this was a lot of questions in one question.
So I had to make it small.
Just an update.
I have had my first of first three of six RGCC.
Vax prep injections about my second week off.
And next week start up again for the next four or six injections.
My ankles have been swollen for the last three plus days.
I started using the rife swelling program a few days ago.
They are still swollen last month.
They were swollen for about a week.
Didn't use the rife and it went away.
What might be causing my ankles to swell?
So usually when your ankles are swelling,
it has to do with them with them.
You start taking a salted tank that can cause some swelling to the ankles.
Heart function is your one of your first things you think of with swollen ankles.
Any impingement.
Clothing or sitting for a long period of time.
So if your ankles drain through the live system to the inferior beta cave.
That goes back to the heart through the iliac veins that come through your gloid area.
So if there's any impingement in that area, it could cause ankles to swell.
If that is a problem after that doesn't go away.
It could be wise to get your heart checked out too.
That's you can always have comorbidity.
You always have the ability to have one thing to wait on.
I don't really want to cancel everything you think it was tied to cancer.
For several weeks each morning when I wake up, I feel pretty good.
But within two hours, I'm exhausted.
So I do not have much activity.
I have been running the right energy and vitality program have not been a city change.
Remember, your live system drains by action up your muscles, your live system doesn't drain by action of your heart.
So this might be tied to the last question above.
So just trying to move your ankles even if you're sitting in a lazy boy chair, start writing the alphabet with your feet.
Getting, getting motion in there.
Even if you're tired, try to stand up and do some leg lifts or some type of simple exercises can be helpful.
Can get motion motion is the key motion is the key to life.
Just always remember that.
So when you're not moving because you're sitting at a computer all day working.
Like sometimes I am or you're just exhausted and you don't all day that can lead to worse problems.
So you want to get up and move around.
Do some squats do a little bit of exercises do something to move your body is simple little calisthenic type exercises.
It doesn't have to be something.
It just needs something that's increasing motion can be really helpful.
The past three weeks I've developed a dry cough.
Suggestions for getting rid of that could this be for the purged older of the tumor, maybe.
I'm concerned about your lungs and anybody has a cough and concerned about your lungs.
So let's go back to home page of the member site and look at the recipe for nebulizing hydro your proxide.
And again, that is just a great thing to do for any issues that's going on in your lungs.
It's a lot of fungal infection at any any pneumonia issues.
The one of the main causes of comorbidity with cancer is the pneumonia and it's oftentimes undiagnosed pneumonia.
So you don't want that to start happening.
So go go back and think about nebulizing hydro proxide for your lungs.
My skin is purple on my right collarbone area and below my deck.
It's personally sent me photos where the collar bones meet the skin is starting to flake off and it's very thin.
Any suggestions to the skin doesn't break open.
What about you the crib seal and carry oil.
This is a.
And oil that a person could get from, you know, from.
There are if they happen if they're using a.
One of my trying to think of the ones here.
Essential oil company. So you can get that from young living, you can get that from an essential company that you might be going through to keep to use an essential oil.
And this can be good for skin issues as well.
I would also think of just using olive oil or coconut oil on it can be beneficial as well.
That could be beneficial for your skin.
We have a company oil, a company, sad that could be really good.
We also have, we have some new tabs that you're going to look at that are really nice.
They can be really good for your skin benefit.
We have a holiday skin special that you're looking to.
Can you please send me by genetic results on the variance.
Yes, I actually sent those to you twice already.
And then I just sent you them again today.
But you have that blocker of your email and I always have to put in my name and information so that email will go through.
Maybe that's why it's not going through.
So I already sent it to you three times.
You didn't get it. Please let us know. We'll try it again.
Can predisode affect tumor markers?
I don't know. I haven't seen any data that predisode will change tumor records, but I just doubt if there's ever been a study on it.
So, I don't know. I don't know.
So, tumor markers are essentially different enzymes that your body cells give off.
Not just cancer cells. You notice if you've ever had done tumor markers that there's a normal range.
Well, the normal range is there because it's normal in your body to have those markers too.
And we call them tumor markers.
But in reality, they are just enzymes that your body makes cancer cells tend to make some cancer cells tend to make access numbers of those enzymes.
And then you can use them as a marker for tumors instead of a tumor markers.
And they're considered in a classification of different tumor markers, but actually normal enzymes that your body makes.
predisode is anti-inflammatory affects the cytokines possibly. I don't know. I cannot.
The man trying to think of the physiology. I don't know that they would.
Maybe there's some weird physiological process that we cause tumor markers to go up, but I don't think so.
So that the chat is fixed on our.
Let's see. Try to fix the chat. Dustin actually turned it off. They had to ask him to turn it back on.
But so you can unmute yourself if you have any other questions.
Okay. Any other questions for anybody?
All right. Well, we will call it a night. This is a short one.
All right. Thank you guys for participating. And we will make sure you get your questions in and talk to you again on Monday.
Remember all your all the zoom calls are available.
I try to get them up the same night. So on.
All right. Thank you guys.
Talk to you next week. Have a good week. Bye.